is now you can focus on your career what  no I put myself out into the world and  it completely rejected me  whoa okay you haven't been single for  that long yeah gotta get around the  board pass go collect 200 when are you  good at one of those alumni events an  alumni event you go and you network with  people and if you really love what you  do then it the whole guy thing is easier  no I don't want to be like you Meg I  don't want my job to be my entire life  oh okay  sisters time out there are pros and cons  to both of you okay  pros young beautiful pros also beautiful  for your age rich doctor access to pills  cons no access to pills cons you really  stingy with the pills bang pros loves me  unconditionally gives me the spare key  to the apartment has a very nice  underwear drawer very neat and organized  you're the key to my apartment calms ask  too many personal questions